okay this next one
uh is from someone i'm gonna read it um
if i can't get back on the jiu jitsu
mats i will kill myself it's my therapy
i need it i am against the lockdown i'm
getting to the edge here i can't hold on
to my sanity
i need jiu jitsu to live that's my
medicine
i i hear you and
you're not alone in feeling that way and
that is not
a resolution to the problem that you are
having there are
many people who have found ways to deal
with the modern condition which is so
unlike any condition that humans have
dealt with before
that requires some modernity such that
exactly the thing that you have clued
together
to deal with modernity can itself be
taken away
by modern decision making and that is
awful and i don't know what the answer
to address that particular conundrum
that many people find themselves in
is well this is a very jarring question
because of course
the idea of self-harm here is both easy
to understand and
such a dire and one-way choice um
i would say there has got to be
and this is something we've been on
about for months now
our failure to understand that there are
things
idiosyncrasies about our situation that
work against us
and there are others that work for us
and we are not leveraging the ones that
work
for us so that we can afford to borrow
more where
we are more constrained and so i would
say look
surely surely there is a way to
reformulate what you're doing
in jiu jitsu so it can be done outside
during the day uv light maybe it has to
be
done with a mask i don't know frankly if
that's possible impossible
imaginable not imaginable i know i don't
feel very good about riding a bike with
a mask but i see people doing it
yeah so i know it's not impossible but
but is there a way
or you know could you have a jujitsu
collective
of people who are hyper vigilant
about protecting themselves get a test
be hyper vigilant about isolation
and participate in a community a jiu
jitsu community
that has very low risk of carrying any
kovid through the door
right and then could you then do it
outside something like that when
you know presuming you're in the
northern hemisphere which most people
are
at the point that it is no longer sunny
out you know
i mentioned a long time ago i haven't
heard anybody respond to it but
you know couldn't we have light bulbs
that put out uv
light when nobody's in the room right
couldn't we have like self-purifying
rooms
in which you know these risks were
reduced yeah can what can you do with
air circulation
right the way we circulate air currently
may make things worse but
really there is a way to circulate air
that would make them
better and you know look you're spelling
out just how
dire the problem actually is it's not an
aesthetic
question this is something built into
you your core
and you need it and we all have those
things and i mean that's that's so key
it's not an aesthetic question and
depending on which site you know which
camp you've decided which tribe you've
decided to belong to
you will have become accustomed to being
mocked by the other side for something
on the basis that this is just your
preference and this is just an aesthetic
thing and that may not be the word that
they use but
it's um it's dehumanizing and
disrespectful and downright mean and
potentially dangerous
uh that um most of us who are functional
have one or a few things that we
actually
really need to do in order to continue
to feel
like full human beings and for almost
everyone
at least one of those things is being
seriously curtailed by this series of
events that we're living through right
now and that is
it makes it no easier at all for the
individual to know that the entire world
to some degree is going through
something similar but it's true
um yeah i think the last thing to say is
you know
heather set it up front you're not alone
frederick hang in there